expansive
and expensive an
empire building exercise or the creation
of a new world trade order
it's not a program dominated by china
it's the program by which china works
with
other countries 10 tentacles that
stretch from china through central asia
to europe
to the middle east and africa to india
and southeast asia
over land and sea through some of the
world's most unchartered economic
territories
defaults can always happen
infrastructure is a risky business
a project that when finished will have
cost china and its partners
trillions of dollars these are countries
that need infrastructure the end of the
day
money will drive this process forward
[Music]
hello i'm stephen engel welcome to a
look at how the economic future
of the world's oldest continuous
civilization is evolving
a new dynasty that's being built from
beijing on the foundations of a project
that is
china's belt and road initiative
fast trains are one of the symbols of
modern china
and so too is the pace at which the
networks are being built
top speed for the trains more than 300
kilometers per hour
and rightly or wrongly in the eyes of
some perhaps
a reflection of china's belt and road
ambitions contrary to some other
people's
misconception it's not a
program dominated by china it's the
program
by which china works with other
countries working with international
financial institutions multilateral
development banks
so it's kind of cooperation
unfortunately some people misunderstood
this as a kind of china program china
wants to
to take advantage of this to promote its
own interests
which nothing could be further from the
truth views on china are often often
mixed china builds up
again enormous amounts of goodwill by
building infrastructure these markets
are desperate for
better metro systems road systems
especially in these small to mid-size
economies where it's not
easy building infrastructure but at the
same time there are some concerns and
one refrain you often hear
uh from from uh from locals whether it's
individuals or companies is that
chinese companies will often uh will
often win or come out on top
in the next 10 or 15 years or next 15
years
the world will invest about 90 trillion
dollars in infrastructure
mostly in emerging market and developing
countries
so whilst that sum is a very large sum
it's only perhaps
a couple of percent or less of the
world's infrastructure
investment and it may be three four five
percent of infrastructure investment
uh in asia so it is very big
but we shouldn't overdo the magnitude of
this in the context of infrastructure
investment
in its simplest form china is looking to
revive the roots of the ancient silk
road with modern infrastructure
economic corridors by road and rail
linking major ports dry and wet to a
maritime silk road that circles back to
china
but the reality is much more complicated
when we have 86 countries
it's very hard for me to say which
country is not part of the better road
you know
initiative and also for instance
traditionally when we think about
maritime silkway it might be
west about but given the increased
relationship between
asia and latin america it could be
eastbound or southwest bound africa
so you see this is really
an effort to promote regional
and global integrations it started out
as a unilateral policy a focus on
infrastructure a focus on
uh relieving excess supply back at home
but it's evolved significantly
since then and what we've seen is a
growing
ecosystem emerge around those
infrastructure projects
a growing number of chinese firms not
just state firms private firms all
looking to participate not just because
of belt and road but simply because the
business opportunities
as a result of the infrastructure spend
the beginning to to grow and to expand
uh so the policy today is very different
to what we saw five years ago
the belt and road initiative is still
very much in its early stages
being designed crafted of course there
are some projects
already through to central asia and the
road down to gwadar in pakistan
but it's in the early stages what we
have seen so far
is that there's a basic idea here which
is
connecting the world to east asia
particularly
china
make no mistake china's leadership is
serious
the project has been enshrined in the
communist party's constitution
and rise or fall the belton road
initiative will be seen
as one of the great legacies of xi
jinping
president xi jinping said very very
clearly we are not going
to build a
garden in our backyard we are
interested in building the beautiful
garden with beautiful flowers
which will be enjoyed by all of the
nations in this world
i think the bri is central to the
strategy of china
and the xi jinping it's about the story
of the rise of china
and the reality of the size of china's
economy and the reality
of the size of china's trade china is
now almost equal in size in its economy
it's united states and it depends how
you measure it
some measurements it would be bigger
much more trade
than united states so the bri is a story
of the rise of china
and the openness of china so in china we
say you aim high
you achieve something a little bit lower
you aim
middle you may achieve you know the
lowest so
the chinese people are very much
ambitious but i would like to say
china would be ambitious for the rest of
the world
there are 10 economies that by
themselves account for
nearly 70 percent of the belton road gdp
chinese firms have won some deals in
these economies
but not too many they are struggling and
in order to compete with the korean the
japanese american the european or the
local firms whether they're indian or
turkish construction companies
chinese firms are going to have to adapt
and that means
collaborating with with foreign or local
partners if an infrastructure
is built in south east asia
or pakistan or kazakhstan or
linking up with africa first and
foremost that infrastructure should be
shaped
by the country in which it is and that i
think is extremely important
in the whole execution of the idea it's
not
a china dictates not china saying this
is what your infrastructure must look
like
that would be a failure new maritime
routes
new roads new railways new pipelines
new ports china's super highway is
taking shape
moving its products to new markets and
bringing the world's offerings
into china up next we'll weigh the risks
versus rewards of doing business through
unchartered territory
one of china's greatest challenges in
realizing its belt and road initiative
will be paying for it the capital scope
for targeted projects ranges from
four to eight trillion dollars but it's
how it manages its money across
countries
with high risk and poor credit profiles
that provides one of the biggest
unknowns
of the 70 or so countries china lists as
partners
the sovereign debt of 27 of them are
rated as junk
or below investment grade another 14 of
them
countries like afghanistan iran and
syria are not rated at all
defaults can always happen
infrastructure is a risky business
in the early stages and that's why it's
so
important to have the right kind of
finance uh
in the right place and the right scale
in the right time and that's what
multilateral development banks try to do
to get involved in the early stages
where
it's risky and manage that risk see the
policy is very clear the bank is
inclusive
and we do not intentionally try to grab
some people
into this bank because it's ultimately
the decision-making
of the sovereign governments and the
door is
open and we are inclusive if they are
interested in joining
and working with other members they are
most welcome
but each and every sovereign government
has its own
ideas too many government to government
deals will be a concern but
again the belt mode initiative is
evolving and in its early stages there
were many government to government deals
increasingly
uh these deals are uh profit driven
done not just between state-owned firms
and local firms but private-owned firms
particularly we're seeing chinese
technology firms beginning to move into
the belt and road markets and looking to
tap what is a very market-driven
consumer opportunity
and what role should and will commercial
banks play
because they're risk adverse as well but
they're being driven by policy in many
places
commercial banks have a very important
role to play particularly the foreign
commercial banks because they provide a
a robust due diligence process to
project
selection project screening and
ultimately of course financing
chinese officials recognize this my
conversations uh
at the highest levels uh often echo
sentiments around well we need the
private banks to participate we need the
foreign banks to participate
we're not going to fund all these
projects but more importantly we don't
want to
see white elephants we want these
projects to be viable
transparency and good governance they're
among the biggest challenges
facing supporters of the belton road
initiative in malaysia a change in
government has seen the new prime
minister
pair back some of the deals signed by
his predecessor and in countries like
sri lanka
a debt default is steering the project
somewhat off course
a couple of countries sri lanka is a
good example
the chinese financed a big port there
but it's actually not very useful
it's not economic so now the chinese
have taken it over
and i think we'll see that in some
smaller more vulnerable countries
you know infrastructure sounds nice but
if it doesn't generate a lot of business
then it's not good infrastructure
you can see that hamban dota port
was taken up without any proper
economic feasibility study sri lanka
ended up
getting into that trap as a result the
government of sri lanka
had to hand over haman to the port
on 99 year lease not just the port
but a vast area of nearly six seven
square kilometers
around it for india
which is the single biggest critic of
the belton road project
it's also a question of national
security
china's biggest project to date runs the
length of neighboring pakistan
to the port of gwadar on the indian
ocean when you talk about
maritime silk road the fact that
today china has come to
acquire control or controlling stakes
in some 75 ports in
35 countries clearly that's not being
done
just with you know commercial objectives
in mind
if you're very close to china then
there's more nervousness
india was a great example but some of
the asean countries
you know they have to worry that there's
a strategic element to this
china's lending a lot of money to
cambodia and lao
it's clearly buying friendship from
those two countries and
they provide a kind of veto within asean
asean operates on a
consensus basis so if you're worried
about south china sea
for example you can count on lao in
cambodia to stick with china
prevent asean from doing anything that
china would find objectionable
we are witnessing rapidly expanding
presence of china and the indian ocean
region in the indo-pacific
we understand that china has desired to
emerge as a major
maritime power we don't quarrel with
that
but what's happening has implications
for us
i think that when you have a rising
power like
china uh countries which are close
neighbors like
india or countries which were the
dominant economic power
like the united states have to think
about
their position and they might get a bit
uneasy because of the strengths
of china and the way in which china
wants to quite understandably and
rightly in my view
link up with the rest of the world and
the rest of the world now means much
more than just routes along the ancient
silk road
globalization connectivity 21st century
transport
and finance it's still very hard to get
uh
clarity around the financing of these
projects
so even in countries such as pakistan
for instance many of these deals
uh all the financing arrangements around
the deals are not made clear
so there are some concerns there that
the chinese well
local governments are overpaying for for
chinese
for chinese contracts the initial set of
chinese loans over the last few years
you know a lot of it's gone to countries
with very poor governance
you know venezuela is a big borrower
sudan angola iran pakistan
these are countries that may very well
run into debt problems
but here's an important but indonesia is
a big borrower
south africa eastern african countries
so i think china has some good clients
some bad clients and what you'd expect
is that the projects would work out in
the better managed countries
at the same time i would say there is a
tendency for people to focus on deals
that were done
five years ago but have only just come
to market whether it's a port
or a rail project when you're deeply
involved as we are
in these projects and you see some of
the deals being done today
they look no different to those that any
other multinational
any other large com country would
would would execute on so that part
uh and it's the most exciting part it's
the one that promises the most over the
coming years
that part's been overlooked
for port operators like hong kong's
modern terminals
the opportunities are massive an
estimated
uplift of two and a half trillion
dollars in trade over a 10-year period
now coming up after the break we're
going to get the word from maersk giant
apm terminals as we continue to navigate
the belt and road initiative
[Music]
so
we're here in xi'an the oldest of
china's four great ancient capitals
home to the han dynasty and the
terracotta warriors
but more importantly on this trip the
easternmost point
of the ancient silk road
[Music]
it's here in xi'an's muslim quarter that
you really can get a sense and quite
literally
a taste of the past much of the
population here are descendants of arab
traders who traveled for months
to get to china along the silk road it's
no surprise to us that china is the
world's largest trading nation
wants to promote world trade uh and we
see very much that belton road is an
initiative that supports that
uh and i think that the overall goal is
to develop an additional 2.5 trillion
dollars
of trade over a 10-year period so some
of these projects
could be very interesting to us as a
transport and logistics provider
and broadly speaking if the trade growth
does come that's more cargo for our
ships it's it's more throughput for our
terminals it's more
uh units in our warehouses you've been
in the shipping and the cargo business
for decades
where do you see the biggest
infrastructure gaps you have to keep
building the connectivity uh our own
research and i think quite a lot of
academic research shows that
when transport connectivity improves the
cost of doing trade comes down
and that has a beneficial impact on
growing trade so
our analysis says a 10 improvement in
connectivity
reduces trade costs by three percent and
increases volumes by you know five to
nine percent
so we see a direct uh you know
connection between these two things
an apm terminal should know the
transport and logistics arm of the
seafaring giant maersk
has 78 port facilities in 58 countries
many of them passing along routes of the
ancient silk road
very much we are looking and have quite
some advanced projects actually
in within the belt and road scope so for
example in vardo in italy
uh we've co-invested with uh costco and
qingdao port group
uh to build a new container terminal and
we're also working with chinese
construction companies
to to build out new ports in africa that
uh where we have some some interest in
investing together
so very much seeing the opportunity not
just within asia but along the whole
scope of the belton road to collaborate
what do you think should be the
priorities in the opening
days or years of this belt and road
initiative i i think it's
for us it's that is the transparency is
the area where we would really like to
see the improvement come you know so
that we can
very often today you know projects are
done uh and we only find out about them
after the
the main players have already reached an
agreement and i think that's probably
where the international companies would
like to get involved
more with the eu i think is very much
communicating along the same lines
uh and it's feedback to china this is an
area where
improving the transparencies is critical
to the future success of belton road
so plenty of roadblocks along the way
but there's also
a sea of opportunity trillions are to be
spent
so who along the belton road stand to
benefit the most
i think they're they're shifting toward
you know better managed countries and
it's a more general
financing of infrastructure so countries
such as brazil or south africa
east africa they have vast
infrastructure needs
and there's a lot of potential for this
to work out you know so if you think of
it as a chinese master plan
for where infrastructure should be
that's not going to work out that's not
realistic
you know the end of the day money is the
ultimate driver here so if
chinese firms can provide elevated or
construct elevated light
rail projects for instance in india if
indian players
whether it's tata or other construction
companies believe there's an opportunity
there
to make money by partnering up with
chinese companies and they'll do so
so at the end of the day money will
drive this process forward
well i think the closest neighbors to
china and those nations
on the route to europe will be the early
beneficiaries that means
central asia and southeast asia but i
hope very much
that the links to south asia
will strengthen particularly to india
because the china-india relationship
is the most important relationship in
the world and secondly
i hope that there will be strong
benefits for
africa to link up with the big
fast-growing markets of the world
which are now asia actually if you read
president xi jinping's i would say
monumental statement in the first
meeting he said belton road initiative
would connect with the other initiatives
proposed by many other countries
so we in adb are very very supportive
of the bell road road initiative of
course
when when we are approached for
financing the projects
we will have to to see whether they meet
our
standards for us the three basic
standards
are as follows financial sustainability
environmental protection and the
protection of the local people's
interests
by the mid 15th century due largely to
more efficient seaborne trade
as well as squabbles between the
participating states the original
overland silk road began its decay
it was about the same time that the
forbidden city here behind me
was being completed to serve as the home
to chinese emperors for the next 500
years
now the revival of the old route is
indicative indeed
of china's re-emergence as a global
trading power
i'm stephen engel thanks for watching